hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey I'm the biggest
Seth Rollins fan you will ever meet in
the history of the WWE and today we are
going to watch Seth Rollins best moments
from the channel ally I'm so queer
excited because the fact of how big of a
fan I am one of her top reporters on
patreon is everybody you requested was
definitely doing put up on the youtubes
today comes from lenay the nay sent us
these awesome shirts and John why are
you letting your [ __ ] hair block the
shirt we're supposed to be able to
represent the shirts that Lynette got us
I'll just tuck this up into this here
half here oh god we don't have time for
all that we already flash the camera
there alright let's let's check this out
for Yulin a I'm ready you realize how
stupid you sounds do you realize how
stupid you look
[Music]
what psyched about that's why I have
that favorite
ladies and gentlemen Avengers I got
skills for SummerSlam Wow
[Music]
let me tell you a little bit about fen
case you didn't know Ben is a former NXT
champion I mean he wasn't he wasn't the
first NXT champion actually that was
that was Seth Rollins I did that thank
you
but last week in the center of this rain
first night on Raw Finn shocked the
world when he pin Roman reigns career
threatening injury and on my first night
back I panned Roman reigns and beat him
for the WWE World Heavyweight
Championship
so you you're all right but I mean
everything you did I kind of did it
first and did it better you're like a
like a bad Hollywood remake like that
new Star Trek or that terrible
ghostbusters right now I'm like the og
Bill Murray and you're kind of like oh
Beck look they think you look pretty
stupid I think you happen to look like
Ronald McDonald with a bad haircut but
if you like don't you dare bring wood
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
was when I took a chair and put it in
your back
[Applause]
this hotel
I'm on an all carb diet God Karen he's
so stupid just not tonight
actually I just spoke with Stephanie
McMahon before I came out here and I'm
feeling kind of jet lag to be honest
tonight my foot playing it hurts a
little bit from Kurt stopping you and
Roman reigns last night so I'm a
fighting champion and I'm going to give
you your rematch just not tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're not all smart if I feel like curb
stomping Paul Heyman tonight at ole I
very much do then
I take away Brock's greatest asset then
at the Royal Rumble Paul I'm narrating
all brawn and no bread then Brock Lesnar
is reduced to be nothing more than a
300-pound mass of muscle that I will run
circles around and I have proven that
John Cena is not a threat to me then
let's face the facts Paul I have curb
stomps your client not once but twice
and at the water Rumble I'm gonna make
it count for the third time when I beat
him and walked out as the WWE Champion
so tell me
I know you're seeing yourself a comedian
ja like that every morning for you is
that joke here nothing to me sounds like
Marc Maron even in that lab you know
what Seth you're right nothing I feel
like that was gross in here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
actually John no the real champ is right
here but I understand what I didn't want
to show up here tonight you look you
look terrible John feel terrible but
wait you feel good enough to show off at
toughen up tomorrow you know I'm
actually going to toughen up to see if I
can apply to be a Connecticut I need to
start over man do not lean all the way
back to square one
this is truly been a life-changing
incident for me you know how I talk
about hustle loyalty and respect now
I've changed them to surgery recovery
and Rehab they're all my C nation out
there to never give up unless of course
Seth Rollins breaks your face then you
should give up wait J is John does that
mean you're giving you up oh yeah come
on look at
I look like I got a nose job from
Picasso well I'm shocked I mean I'm
shocked but John you know what you're
doing the right thing because the WWE
Universe deserves a fighting champion
and that fighting champion is Seth
Rollins that's right people
burn it down never giving up well you
can own it all you want
Roman because the bottom line is I own
you I've always owned your Roman I owned
you last year WrestleMania when I beat
you and the center that's right
for the WWE hate for life
feel like Jake Gyllenhaal is gonna play
this guy someday well Michael Fassbender
put your hands on me again
I'm the World Heavyweight Champion you
know what I hope I hope that Triple H
and Stephanie named you my next opponent
look at you you're a sad excuse for a
human being and you're gonna be put on
your
[Music]
[Music]
the best time I ever had in a ring with
you guys
[Music]
was when I took a chair and put it in
your back
then Oh Dean I know you weren't there
but this was a big shield moment you
about a Wrestlemania when I stole your
moment cashed in my Money in the Bank
contract then became the first member of
the shield to hold that World
Heavyweight Championship huh
those are some good moments right
John I didn't want it to come to this
you leave me no choice but to force
yours oh wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
damn bumblebee yeah yeah yeah big and
big cuddly john cena bumblebee and that
same scene plays out he's like you know
there's a Decepticon standing over be
and he's like bring back the authority
and let me go Wow it's great yeah that's
why Seth Rollins is the man yeah he's a
confident guy he's Robert De Niro in
Cape Fear actually if you gave him a
beard and neck Aziz even got the long
hair in that movie are you in love
I haven't that's your boy right there
you see his face I imagine a different
voice is very marc maron Jewish voice I
know you got that like Frye and he's got
that gravel a little bit of the nasal -
yeah yeah you have Seth Rollins
my favorite part of this was the last
minute a real intense like traumatic
moment and watching him I lose his [ __ ]
on John Cena John Cena getting all
concerned like okay that's some good
teamwork right there yeah when they do
one or two of the bits really kind of
stretch out for a minute so you can't
immerse yourself in the pageantry of it
all in the you know [ __ ] talking and all
that stuff I still don't know what makes
Seth Rowling's the
and I mean it like he was like doing all
kinds of flips the curb stopping and
everything which is pretty cool
I like its heel personality because at
first he looks like it's kind of a cool
down to earth guy and then you see he's
really good that [ __ ] talking he's
retaining i love this i just love as we
were left yeah yeah as weird laughs and
his confidence he just always seems like
he's ready to level somebody had ready
to prove these the best even when he's
you know the couple moments where it
seems like he was in defeat I guess that
was what I was expecting out of this
more than like his best talking like you
know hyping himself up moments I thought
this was gonna be like a compilation of
him just like kicking dudes asses
apparently not what's what every morning
I get up in John's face right here a
trailer drop John and I'm gonna lead the
[ __ ] video John how this channel is
started I mean he's a high guy he's a
hot guy some of these wrestlers look
cool look intimidating look buff look
goofy but he's a guy that I I feel like
ladies would love like he's a really
good-looking dude well yeah long hair
the perfectly groomed facial hair he's
like a just a really good-looking dude
and it's always slick you know like he
just got out the shower yeah we're done
sweating a loss one one of the two oh
dude his knickers really holy Daniel
Lopez really none of those letters are
in Seth Rollins Oh like a customer he's
like Latino he's sex not Jewish
turns out other people can have nasal
gravelly voice he's Armenian German and
Irish descent surname Logan car service
mexican-american stepfather okay that
makes more sense
hmm yeah I could see the Armenian that's
our commentary oh there you go I was
wondering that yeah part of his name is
a tribute to Henry Rollins I was gonna
make a joke gonna say that too it's so
funny well were you you had Black Flag
been there and his mom is Cobie Smulders
yeah that excitement knowing that piece
of information
Lynnae I still love this shirt I do too
when are we gonna get an AJ video my
girlfriend loves this shirt and I think
that in the unboxing video when I took
my shirt off
it says changing this one that was
probably your favorite part of the video
let's face it the name you are the rare
case where you find me more physically
attractive than John and I can live with
that
I can live with that but I'm taking my
Liam nice yeah I hope you have a Merry
Christmas I know your grandparents had a
bit of a scare there for a hot second
but I'm glad they're doing better so you
better get them some bomb-ass Christmas
presents this December 25th and I hope
you cook some disgusting ass fried food
in order to make their health that much
better come Christmas mmm barbecue
eggnog let's do it whoo yeah look at
that right I love you Lynnae this shirt
it's awesome
this shirts more awesome when John
please got like please this is Seth
Rollins video I know I just wanted to
feel special well you don't look special
to me